Ananas auf der Pizza
ich muss das ich als riesiger
neapolitanischer Pizza Fan bin ganz
ehrlich finde es schmeckt nicht so krass
schlimm wie es der ganze Held vermuten
lässt aber
immer noch Blech Nutella mit Butter
völlig akzeptiert
Marmelade mit Butter
schwierig akzeptiere ich auch noch mit
dem Messer mit dem man vorher in der
Butter war dann auch ins Marmeladenglas
gehen halt eher Quatsch anderer Löffel
bevor man da wieder in seiner Marmelade
oder auch bei einer Nutella dann in
Butter Reste drin Alter komplett auf
Butter Margarine keine Ahnung was alles
verzichten und Brot trocken mit
Aufschnitt oder so essen nee da muss was
saftiges drauf oder Butter okay die ist
jetzt nicht saftig aber irgendwas
lustiges so muss
erst die Cornflakes dann die Milch no
joke wäre es andersrum macht und erst
die Milch einfüllt und dann die Kellogs
oben drauf oder müsst ihr keine Ahnung
was Digger
der abonniert diesen Kanal ich sag's dir
wie es ist noch gar kein Intro gemacht
ne hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde wir schauen uns heute ganz ganz
viele verschiedene Dinge an wo ganz ganz
viele verschiedene Leute eine ganz ganz
verschiedene Meinung haben
ja das hätte eigentlich schon vor ein
paar Minuten kommen sollen das Andrea
also auf jeden Fall bei diesem
Cornflakes Beispiel es ist einfach nur
kompletter Schwachsinn erst die Milch
reinzumachen und dann die Cornflakes und
sind ja auch die die Cornflakes Sieger
noch alle obendrauf du weißt doch gar
nicht wie viel du dann rein machen musst
also es ist wirklich einfach Quatsch
erst Müsli dann Milch und dann die
Schale
KitKat so abbeißen Bruder
no joke du kommst einfach in die Hölle
auf Rolltreppen einfach nebeneinander
stehen nee ich weiß nicht ob da mein
alman Herz höher schlägt oder so aber du
musst auf Rolltreppen rechts stehen
rechts stehen links gehen und wenn ihr
zu zweit seid oder zu dritt dann stellt
euch auf die rechte Seite hinter oder
dementsprechend halt voreinander kommt
drauf an welche Richtung ihr da gerade
hat aber es gibt immer Leute wie mich
die zu spät dran sind würden Zug 5 Flug
am Flughafen gibt's wieder Rolltreppen
oder einfach keine Ahnung bisschen
schneller dran vorbei gehen wollen oder
nicht stehen wollen das ist so dumme
Zeitverschwendung ich habe doch diese
Menschen die gehen wenn sie in durch die
Stadt laufen die gehen ein km/h ne liebe
Grüße gehen raus an Sandra geht raus
langsames fortbewegen ist die größte
Zeitverschwendung auf der ganzen Welt
nach schlafen
schlafen ist wirklich Quatsch no joke
wir schlafen acht Stunden am Tag das ist
ein Drittel unseres kompletten Lebens
die wir einfach nur schlafen
früher ich war der größte Langschläfer
der jede Nacht mindestens 9 Stunden
Schlaf mittlerweile ich bin bei 5 bis 6
Stunden ich will meine Zeit nicht
verschlafen und erst recht nicht auf
einer Rolltreppe warten müssen weil so
zwei excused wir haben 2022 Idioten da
stehen machen wir allerdings weiter mit
dem nächsten Beispiel wo ich glaube die
Meinungen sich auch so ein bisschen
trennen werden Zahnpasta auf
verzahnbürste in eine Zahnbürste hast
nimmst du die machst die nass dann
machst du deine Zahnpasta drauf dann
machst du noch mal nass und dann putze
die Zähne
es gibt ja Leute machen Zahnbürste nass
Zahnpasta drauf dann putzen nee die
Zahnpasta muss doch auch noch mal nass
werden dieser juice Faktor am besten
auch noch bekomme ich mir die noch
Butter auf der Zahnpasta Getränke in der
Mikrowelle warm machen warum
warum muss man sich Getränke überhaupt
nochmal warm machen also ich bin ja
überhaupt kein also wirklich absolut gar
kein Fan von warmen Getränken okay im
Winter man geht eine Runde spazieren es
liegt vielleicht Schnee schön durch den
Park sonst schön Pfefferminztee ne
generell Tees okay aber so warm Glühwein
nee brauche ich nicht oder Kaffee oder
irgendwie sowas auf gar keinen Fall und
dann noch mal zweite Lage aufgewärmt
Alter auf gar keinen Fall das ist so wie
wenn man mit der Ex wieder
zusammenkommen Klopapier so rum
aufhängen nee Bro wenn dir dein Hirn
geschissen Klopapier wird nicht so rum
aufgehangen sondern so rum Verpackungen
an der falschen Stelle aufreißen finde
ich überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn ich
persönlich irgendwas geiles bestelle und
mit geil meine ich jetzt nicht irgendwie
okay komm ich bestelle mir irgendwie was
zu essen was lecker ist oder so da finde
ich schon bei essen muss es richtig
aufgemacht werden
sonst machst du da irgendwas kaputt
vermischt irgendwas dumm oder als keine
Ahnung wie aber wenn man wirklich was
geiles bestellt keine Ahnung ein neues
Handy oder einen neuen Laptop oder den
Technik oder Konsole oder Spieler oder
so einfach aufreißen
einfach ich will einfach das Produkt
haben so schnelles geht aber bei sowas
Digger cleaning Vibes kommen leck meine
Arsch apropos Arsch allerdings meine
lieben Freunde kommen direkt zur
nächsten Sache Arsch abwischen machen
anscheinend übel viele im Stehen als
ergonomischer ist was Bruder wenn wir
uns generell über Toilette unterhalten
müssen wir uns auch über Klopapier
unterhalten es ist einfach Schwachsinn
dass wir unser Arschloch abwischen mit
Papier warum nutzt man dafür nicht
Wasser was hast du wenn du hier
irgendwie Hundekot dran hast am Arm
nimmst du dann Papier oder Wäsche das
unterm Wasser so braucht man nicht
weiter drüber reden Klopapier generell
einfach dumm aber gar nicht primär gehen
meine lieben Freunde denn es geht
hierbei wirklich nur darum dass Leute
häufig sich den Arsch nur mit zwei
klopapierstücken übereinander abwischen
checke ich jetzt nicht aber ich bin so
Mensch ich verwöhne meinen Arsch auch
ich habe viel lagiges Klopapier manchmal
sogar fünf wenn ich komplett ausraste
aber ich bin frisch dicker
viele benutzen ja auch das hier für ein
Arsch ne aber das ist Quatsch
Feuchttücher für ein Arsch das brennt
auf Dauer das ist das ist nicht gut
nimmt schönes mehrleibiges brennt
wenn euer Arschloch brennt backt
bisschen Nivea Creme drauf bisschen
Penaten Creme ein bisschen Arschloch
einreiben
während des Duschens pinkeln alle schon
mal gemacht ist auch satisfying weil
Wasser kommt von oben und man scheidet
selber Wasser aus und alles fließt ab
das ist ja auch ein Weg um generell
Wasser zu sparen effizient weil man zwei
Sachen direkt miteinander verbindet muss
kein Klopapier eventuell benutzen aber
viel schlauer bevor ihr eine
Spülmaschine anstellen ne mit äh
dreckigen Geschirr einfach nur mal
reinpissen
ihr lernt hier richtig was hopel unter
dem Tisch abschmieren
ich esse die immer no job bei mir damals
in der Grundschule hat einer die ganze
Zeit seine Popel gefressen und dann
musste der einfach nachher seinen Magen
ausgelernt bekommen weil das irgendwie
nicht so richtig verarbeitet wurde aber
der hat auch so so schnoddert er dann
auch so abgelegt ja der ganz andere Liga
also Popel Essen geht gar nicht finde
ich aber auch popeling wo abschmieren
geht nicht wenn man so ein richtig
geilen fetten harten Popel hat einfach
wegschmeißen oder in der Vitrine
wenn man abends auf Toilette gegangen
ist nicht abspülen um Wasser zu sparen
und um am nächsten Morgen abzuspülen
wenn man dann morgens pinkeln war ja
auch
müssen wir gar nicht lange Zeit
verlieren das Brotmesser in die
Spülmaschine packen und nötig
nachdem man Brötchen geschnitten hat
einfach mit den Fingern nehmen kurz
abstreichen oder mit dem Handtuch einmal
kurz sie damit man sich nicht schneidet
Ende Gelände ab wieder einen Messerblock
in der Wohnung eine Jacke tragen wir
machen das ja in den kalt ist ziehen die
sich eine Jacke an oder wenn die gerade
von draußen kommen und die sind noch
nicht wieder aufgewärmt lassen Jacke
erstmal nein der Körper wärmt die Stelle
auf wenn die Jacke aussieht
ich sag's euch heute bin ich euer Lehrer
Koriander komplett weg braucht man nicht
soll verboten werden es war nicht drüber
reden minzschokolade kann sich direkt im
Koriander anschließen ab nach Timbuktu
mit dir dich mit der Kleidung die man
tagsüber anhatte dann abends ins Bett
legen überhaupt nicht schlimm
ich habe letzten tiktok dazu gesehen
wieder eine meinte das kann doch nicht
sein dass T-Shirt hattest du doch schon
den ganzen Tag an die ganzen Namen jetzt
ins Bett gehen hey
eben genau deswegen man schwitzt ja über
Nacht dann kannst du am nächsten Morgen
eine Wäsche warum ziehen wir zum
frisches T-Shirt an was dann auch am
nächsten Morgen eine Wäsche muss einfach
effizienter nackt schlafen nee
also wie gesagt ich wenn ich schlafen
gehe ich nehme meine boxershot die ich
den Tag waren hatte und das T-Shirt was
den Tag waren hatte heute Nacht wenn ich
in diesem T-Shirt und in meiner
Boxershort dich gerade einmal ich bin
gerade nackt und zu guter Letzt haben
wir dann noch Sushi bin ich ganz ehrlich
kann meiner Ansicht nach direkt mit der
minzschokolade und dem Koriander seine
Koffer packen und nach dem Buch zu
reisen
wie seht ihr diese ganzen Punkte
schreibt mir nicht in die Kommentare